un constat est un processus évolutif à
la nouvelle heure très grave à prendre
sa place à l' usage la langue française
était trop compliqué à apprendre faut-il
la rendre plus facile en simplifiant
l'orthographe
par exemple en chassant les accents
circonflexes et les traits d'union
ces changements proposés par l'académie
française vous l'imaginez provoque
énormément de réactions dans toute la
francophonie
alors qu'en est il exactement fenech est
ce qu'on peut parler d'une nouvelle
orthographe vraiment mais bonne question
céline toute votre attention maintenant
sur le tableau s'il vous plaît regardez
bien les mots suivants oignons nénuphars
chariot et tire bouchon est ce qu'il ya
des erreurs dans ce tableau la baie de
ce côté et moi jusqu'à pas de délire là
là je commence à trouver
et pourtant en fait nénuphars avec un
effet chariot avec deux r en fait c'est
accepter par cette nouvelle orthographe
mais en fait c'est pas si nouveau que ça
en fait ça date de 1990 et lorsque
l'académie française avaient accepté ces
modifications et c'est en fait la
belgique la suisse et le québec qui ont
emboîté le pas à partir de 2008 mais là
c'est rentrer dans les programmes
scolaires en france figurez vous et
pourquoi on parle de cette nouvelle
orthographe aujourd'hui c'est parce que
dès septembre 2016 en fait la plupart
des éditeurs de manuels scolaires en
france ont décidé d'incorporer cette
nouvelle orthographe et donc ça concerne
2400 mot 4% du lexique de la langue
française
alors à quoi ressemblent ces
modifications vont aller montrer
quelques exemples alors en voici
d'autres mais justement parlé tout à
l'heure de petits chapeaux l'accent
circonflexe épaule quand même c'est
facultatif tout ça ça ne fait pas
enlever l'ancienne orthographe donc par
exemple c'est devenu facultatif l'accent
circonflexe sur les i il ait eu par
exemple coup on peut l'écrire son petit
chapeau
sauf pour les distinctions de sens et
les internautes se sont beaucoup amusés
avec sens en disant mon métier ainsi
georges si j'enlève le l'accent
circonflexe de jeunes bah ça peut prêter
à confusion dont je vais me faire un
p'tit jeune avec ou sans chapeau donc
c'est assez étrange mais quand même si
le sens et changer à cause d'un accent
circonflexe en fait il va quand même
rester les accents par exemple
maintenant l'accent aigu peut devenir
aussi le graff
on peut écrire réglementaires ou
réglementaires céleri ou céleri
c'est un peu étrange mais c'est accepter
maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on va faire au canada alors
au canada mais c'est intéressant parce
que dans le fond
bon bah on va simplifier donc oignons
pour cours millions parce que y'a pas
besoin de vie dans le fond pourquoi on
écrit aiguë avec le tréma sur lui plutôt
que là mais c'est logique un peu l'idée
c'est de corriger des anomalies par
exemple souffler et boursouflée on
aurait dû mettre de f dans souffler et
boursouflé mais maintenant on va pouvoir
d2f d'hambourg souffler alors pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
ici au canada mais la directive c'est
d'accepter les deux orthographes partout
au canada et le ministère de l'éducation
en tout cas ici au québec a dit pour
l'instant pas question de changer les
manuels scolaires donc pour l'instant ça
reste comme ça mais par exemple
l'enseignant qui va devoir corriger des
va devoir accepter les deux orthographes
et pour tous ceux qui pensent que
finalement tout ça c'est un nivellement
par le bas
et bien sachez que maintenant ça s'écrit
soit avec deux ailes ou bien avec un
accent grave je suis sans mots parfois
non à des rites exemple